IMAX theaters are known worldwide as D
plays to see the biggest movies now
IMAX is coming to one of London's most
iconic world premiere cinemas this is a
behind-the-scenes look at the technology
designed and customized to deliver the
IMAX experience to Empire Leicester
Square
this is I'm access Technology Center
where we design the manufacturer sound
and projection systems but we're
actually much more than that
we offer cameras for the point of image
capture to drive digital remastering
technology where we enhance image
through two projection and sound systems
and all of this is coupled together in
our immersive IMAX theater geometry i'm
access theater geometry is really all
about creating an immersive experience
for the audience our screens are
slightly curved they extend from wall to
wall
for to ceiling and they're positioned
closer to the audience than a normal
screen in the theater all of this works
together to create a very wide field of
view filling your peripheral vision and
in effect putting you the audience right
in the middle of the story there's
nothing normal about the IMAX projection
system it uses custom design lenses to
create that wide field of view that you
see on the screen and the dual
projectors provide the brightest images
and the highest contrast in the industry
and in 3d unlike the single projectors
that have to alternate the left and the
right eye we're using two projectors
that give you the image at the same time
and you have no 3d artifacts these two
projectors behind me once completed
their testing are actually going to be
shipped out to Leicester Square
another element that is affected by the
imax theater geometry is the design of
the screen itself IMAX screens differ
from conventional screens certainly in
shape and size but they're also coated
with a very special paint that maximizes
light reflectivity back to the audience
the Leicester Square screen is five
stories tall and almost 90 feet wide for
IMAX Sound is just as important as the
picture you don't just hear it feeling
behind the screen and at the rear of the
theater we have canga loudspeakers Keng
and loudspeakers are custom designed and
hand-built by imax there's going to be
six kangas installed in the theater
along with up to six sub bass and with
this configuration along with the
technology we call phantom imaging we
can create a fully immersive 3d sound
environment next stop is empire
Leicester Square
once all the equipment arrives the
installation begins